[Music]
So voice is the most natural of
interfaces.
Humans are storytellers, talkers,
listeners, conversationalists.
We think out aloud. We learn to talk
before we learn to read. And most of us
talk faster than we type. We express
emotion through our voices. And we use
sound to understand the world around us.
We've been working together for the past
few months. Shita from the angle of
models and APIs and me from the
application layer and agent framework
direction. And I think we both believe
that voice is a critical and universal
building block for the whole next
generation of of Gen AI, especially at
the UI level, but more generally as
well. I mean, those of us who are early
adopters of personal voice AI talk to
our computers all the time. Uh we think
of the LLMs we talk to as sounding
boards and coaches and interfaces to
everything that lives on our devices and
in the cloud. And this is not just an
early adopter phenomenon, right? Like we
already have voice agents deployed at
scale, language translation apps that
translate between a patient and a
doctor, directed learning apps that a
fourth grader can use to learn a topic
they want to, speech therapy apps, and
co-pilots that help people navigate
complex enterprise software. One of the
things we see in our work with customers
at Daily is it's pretty common for
people not to realize that they're
talking to a voice agent on a phone
call, even when you tell them at the
beginning of the phone call that they're
talking to an AI.
Yeah. And kids born today will probably
take all of this for granted. But those
of us who are living through this
evolution of talking computers, this can
sometimes feel like magic. But of
course, anybody who's seen a really
great magician prepare a magic trick
knows that the magic is just the
interface. There's a lot of hard work
that goes into creating that magic
trick.
So, here's a partial list of the hard
things that done right collectively add
up to that magic. So real-time
responsiveness which we've all in this
whole track all day talked about as the
foundation thing you have to get right
or voice AI is unworkable through the
things that we're just starting to
experiment with like generating dynamic
user interface elements for every
conversational turn. These are the
things we've been hacking on and
thinking about together for the past few
months and we're not going to go over
all of these today although we did have
a little extra time in the session right
Thor Thor said we could talk for like a
couple hours maybe. Um, but we do have a
framework that we thought would be
useful to share with you. A framework
that sort of maps onto how we've worked
together from the model layer all the
way up. Yeah. And this barely scratches
the surface, but here are the layers of
the voice AI stack. So at the bottom
underpinning everything, you have the
large language models uh that frontier
labs like DeepMind work on. Then above
that you have carefully designed but at
this stage constantly evolving real-time
APIs. Google's version is called the
Gemini live API. Um above the APIs are
the orchestration libraries and
frameworks like Pipcat that help to
manage and abstract away the complexity
of building these realtime multimodal
applications. And then of course at the
top of the stack you have the
application code.
For each of the hard things we listed on
the previous slide, the code that
implements that hard thing lives
somewhere in that stack. So one of the
ways we think about this is that there's
a map and you can sort of think about it
two dimensionally. Maybe there's the
where does the code live that kind of
solves the hard problem that you're you
know you're thinking about as a voice
agent developer where in the stack and
then how mature is our solution to that
right now. Yeah. Basically how solved is
this thing and what we've tried to do
here is map all of these various things
that you need to get right on a right to
left axis of maturity. And there are a
couple of things that are kind of top of
mind for me about this mapping. One is
that I don't think of any of these
things as more than about 50% solved.
Totally arbitrary like personal thing.
Stress and I argued about it a little
bit like what's the right way to
represent that on this slide. But what
we're trying to say is basically it's
early. It's early for voice AI and
there's a lot of work to do at every
part of the stack to get to that
universal voice UI we're imagining.
Yeah. And secondly, um, as this
technology matures, and we've already
seen some of this happening, um, the
capabilities tend to move down the
stack. So what might happen is in your
one-off individual applications, you
might write some code to solve a
specifically difficult challenge. Now if
enough people experience that challenge
then that tends to get built into the
orchestration libraries and frameworks
and then eventually make its way into
the APIs.
But indep independently all of all of
that the models themselves are getting
more and more generally capable. I mean
we just talked about semantic voice
activity detection in the previous talk.
So yeah, this is like a great like
follow on to Tom's talk about about turn
detection because I think turn detection
is a perfect example of this. So like I
built some of the first talk to an LLM
voice AI applications a little over two
years ago now and I tried to solve turn
detection right there in the application
code because there weren't any tools yet
for it. A few months later we built what
we thought were pretty generalized at
the time state-of-the-art turn detection
implementations into Pipcat. So move
down the layer into the framework. Now
Trista has turn detection in the
multimodal live API sort of inside the
surface area of those same APIs that are
doing inference and other things for
you. And I think all of us as Tom said
expect the models over time to just do
turn detection for us and all those hard
things. I mean it varies depending on
exactly what you're talking about of
that long list we put out together on
that slide. But in general, I think
everything is moving down the stack and
then more and more interesting use cases
are creating more things to put sort of
at the top of the stack. Yeah, I will
say we have serverside turn detection
built in, but we also allow you to turn
off turn detection and use models like
uh daily and uh live kit.
So should we start with the demo? Yeah,
we can. We do have a demo to show you.
Um, and it's it's sort of a demo of some
stuff I've been using in my own life
every day for the last year or so. Uh,
I've been experimenting with talking to
my computer and my phone as much as I
can to do various things. Um, as you can
imagine, because I post about it
probably too often on social media. And
one of the things that's become really
sticky for me is is kind of managing my
priorities in like a very loose way with
voice AI. Uh these days the
conversations I have with my phone and
my computer often tend to be in this
sort of funny and interesting and new
gray area for me between like a to-do
list and brainstorming or kind of trying
to work stuff out. Um and because I
write this code for myself and am always
messing with it. This is definitely a
cobbler's children never wear shoes
situation. Like I don't have unit tests.
I don't have evals for this code. I'm
always using like Trisha's latest
models. I'm always using some bleeding
edge branch of Pipecat. So, what I
thought would be fun to do is fire up a
version of this code, have Shista talk
to it, and see what breaks and then
maybe we can talk about like where those
bugs are and like how I could have done
better next time.
Yeah, I will say having played with this
there's quite a lot of variation in how
the model behaves. So, we'll see where
we get today. One thing that I think is
interesting is as I write more and more
of this code, I keep relearning the
lesson that the way the models drive the
whole application cycle is very
different from my traditional
programmer's view of things. So half the
things I'm sure you encountered when you
were like playing with this are the
model did something that my code
actually didn't expect. That might have
been bad, but it might actually been
good. And that's a whole sort of
adjustment to how we think about these
applications. Yeah, there's definitely
pleasant surprises also.
I am ready.
Okay. Do I talk? I think you can just
talk. And I don't think I can mute it
because I don't know how to use the
mouse backwards very well. Okay. Yeah,
you can talk whenever you're ready.
No problem. I'm here to help whenever
you need. Yep. I can hear you loud and
clear.
All right.
Okay. What can I help you with today?
Yes. Can you help me create a grocery
list for asparagus pizza?
Got it. Pizza ingredients are added to
your Gury list. Anything else? Can you
list out the pizza ingredients for
asparagus pizza, though?
Sure. I've updated the grocery list to
include pizza crust, mozzarella cheese,
tomato sauce, and asparagus. Anything
else?
Would you add anything else to the list?
I've added garlic and olive oil to the
list. Does that sound right? That sounds
perfect. All right. Now, let's create my
reading list. So, great.
Can you create to start adding to your
reading list? Okay, great. Absolutely.
What books would you like to have? Yeah.
Uh, okay. reading list. Um,
can you add the please add the first
book, Dream Count, and can you look up
the author? I've added Quick, to your
reading list. No, that was not the book
I wanted to add. Please add the first
book, Dream Count, and look up the
author for me.
Hey, are you there?
Got it. Segmentation fault is added to
the reading list. What's next?
I guess I'll have to
It really couldn't find the author for
that one.
But let's try one last time. Okay, one
more book, Dream Count. And can you look
up the author?
Hey, are you there?
Segmentation.
Okay, segmentation has been added to
your reading.
It just likes your voice better than
mine.
All right. No, segmentation fault is
great, but I would really like to read
dream count. Can you add dream count?
All right. Hey, are you still there?
Yes, I'm still here. How can I help you?
Okay. Can you add the second and third
books of the threebody problem trilogy?
The second and third both segmentation
fault and sec while segmentation add the
second and third books of the three
concept. Is there anything else I can
help you with?
I swear it worked much better 10 times
last night. Um I apologize for my
performance isn't up to par today. Is
there anything specific you'd like me to
try again? Well, maybe you can try. All
right, but but um let's recover here.
Please add the second and third books of
the Threebody Problem trilogy.
you want to add the second and third
books of the Three Body Problem trilogy.
I've added I just want to point out that
it did look up the names and find it. Uh
let's see if it'll collaborate.
Yeah, compound Google search with this
one might be in its training data
because it's a bit older. But the dream
count one which it was spectacular on
last night. It did a Google search
because it's a new book. All right,
let's move on. Can you create a new list
for me called work tasks?
So, first item I would like to say
create H2 road map by end of day Friday.
Got it. Create H2 road map by end of day
Friday is added to your worklist. I
don't see it. Can you show me on the
screen?
I've displayed the worklist for you. All
right. You should see. Let's add another
item. Um, okay. Finish it. Writing
podcast script by end of day Thursday.
And can you add the exact date?
Okay. I've added finish writing podcast
script by end of day Thursday to your
worklist. What's the exact date for end
of day Thursday?
Today is Wednesday, June 4th, 2025. So,
end of day Thursday is June 5th, 2025.
Can you add that to the list?
Yes, I have added the exact date to the
worklist. All right. It now says finish
writing podcast script by end of day
Thursday, June 5th, 2025. Is there
anything else you'd like to add to the
list or anything else? Yes, I would. Can
you combine my grocery list, my reading
list, and my work list and split them
into two lists, personal tasks and work
tasks?
I've combined your grocery list, reading
list, and worklist. They are now
displayed on the screen as separate
lists.
Why are garlic oil garlic and olive oil
separate from pizza ingredients? Can you
flesh out the grocery list, please?
You're right. I've updated the grocery
list to include garlic and olive oil as
part of the pizza ingredients. All
right. And can you consolidate the
worklist? I see two on the screen.
You're right. I apologize for the
duplication. I've consolidated the
worklist to a single entry. You should
now see the updated list on the screen.
Okay. And then finally,
can you do the following? Can you assign
grocery list to Quinn, reading list to
Shishta with the exception of
segmentation fault which Quinn will read
and work list to shta?
I understand you want to assign the
grocery list to Quinn, the reading list
to Shaa, except for segmentation fault,
which Quinn will read, and the work list
to Sha as well. Can you show that on the
screen?
I've updated the lists to show the
assignments you specified. You should
now see the updated lists on the screen.
And you've spelled my name correctly,
which was the harder name, but you
spelled Quinn incorrectly. Um, but okay.
We'll don't we're out of time here.
Okay. So, we want the final thing here
is we would like to have a nice
background for this app. So, can you I
apologize for spelling your Okay. Could
you help us generate actually I'll be
more assertive. Please generate
a an app that has the words hello world
jumping up and down on the screen with
the colors of Google. And then we also
want two neon green asi cats which are
animated.
I'm now generating an app with hello
world jumping up and down in Google
colors and two animated neon green asky
cats. It may take a moment for the app
to appear on your screen.
detention.
[Applause]
So yeah, there you have the Google
colors and the cats from Pipecat. So
with that, I'll hand it over to Quinn.
So, first thank you should go back to
your pride of place right in the middle.
Um, thank you for being such a good
sport. Uh, very messy code on my part,
including things like basically no
instructions to the LLM about how to
display text on the screen and just
telling it it has a function that can
display text on the screen and it sort
of guesses and learns in context as you
can tell from Trista about when it
should clear the screen because there's
an optional clear argument to the add
text to the screen function. And it's
super impressive but also super jagged
frontier about whether it kind of can
intuitit what you want to do in those
contexts. So thank you for like doing
this because this is what I do all the
time with this code trying to figure out
like what these models can do and what
kind of code you have to write and what
you don't have to scaffold for them to
do well. Yeah. And it's been you know
playing with this every turn is
different. And it's interesting to see
the things that it struggles with like
your name. Even if I spell out the exact
letters, it somehow really wants to
spell Quinn the way it spells. I think
it also um I mean turn detection as we
saw there's a lot of work that can be
done of course there. Um, and I'm trying
to remember there's and there's of
course a lot of variation in sometimes
here like there are times when it gets
the grocery list perfect and you know
combines the list perfectly and
sometimes it's a bit in the middle like
here and the way this code works is it
just for a given like session it loads
lots and lots and lots of previous
conversational sessions in user
assistant user assistant sort of
messages does sometimes depending on the
version of the code I've like got
running it summarizes a little bit
sometimes it doesn't so we really are
leaning on the intelligence of the LLM
to do all of the sort of contextual
understanding about what we mean by a
list, what we mean by the context in
that in which we are talking about that
list. It is super amazing that it that
it works at all basically in my mind and
it's all voice driven and it's all
multimodal from the ground up. Um, we
have a whole another video we can show,
but I I definitely think we're we're out
of time. So, we will you final talk and
everyone seems to be excited.
One minute to talk about our
grandmothers. Oh, yes. I totally forgot
that part. Sorry. Let's skip past the
demo where it gets the grocery list
perfect. I think maybe maybe this crowd
would like to see that demo. So, that
was great. Um, so this has been fun for
me to work on because like it's so
relevant to my everyday life, but and
Sha and I were talking about it and I
think there's actually something else
that really kind of hooked me that she
said. Yeah. So, you know, u my
grandmother was Indian, of course, and
she used to wear this cloth garment
called a sari. and her way of reminding
herself when she had to do things was
tying knots on the sari. Uh, of course u
and then I was chatting with Quinn and
what was incredible is apparently his
grandmother in North Carolina so very
different from Kolkata in India used to
uh tie strings around her fingers. Um
and firstly, you know, this is kind of
incredible. You know, no matter how many
continents separate us, like smart
people come up with the same generally
intelligent patterns, but it's also
incredible how technology allows humans
to evolve. Now, the the one problem with
either the knots or the strings is you
knew you had to remember something, but
you didn't know what it was. So, you
still relied on your memory. And you
know ultimately that's why I do the work
I do at Google because I want to build
the technologies that enable you know an
infinite world of creative possibilities
tomorrow or even today across
continents. Um and I just want to say
that we believe that voice is the most
natural of interfaces and there will
come a most of the interaction with
language models will happen via voice.
And the Gemini models are trained to be
multimodal from the ground up. So of
course they ingest text, voice, but also
images and video. So if you have any
questions about Gemini, please reach out
to me on on X, on LinkedIn, email,
wherever. Happy to work with builders
like yourself. Yeah, thanks for coming
to the talk and we would love to see
what you build with these models and
APIs.
[Applause]
[Music]